[Música]
en venezuela fue restablecido el
suministro de energía tras un apagón que
afectó a 20 de los 23 estados del país
el gobierno insiste en que se debió a un
ataque en la hidroeléctrica del gurí que
es la principal fuente de energía
tenemos información desde caracas la
capital venezolana
la variante omicron es resistente a las
vacunas de kobe 19 existentes así lo
determinó un estudio de la universidad
de columbia que indicó que su gran
cantidad de mutaciones afectan la
eficacia de las vacunas y de las
terapias de anticuerpos que hay
disponibles
el jefe de la dinastía que gobierna a
corea del norte kim jong-un cumplió 10
años de haber llegado al poder se mostró
como un reformador pero ha mantenido la
mano dura contra su pueblo también ha
llevado al aislamiento internacional y
mantiene las constantes amenazas bélicas
a países vecinos ya occidente
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia vamos a
comenzar en venezuela en donde fue
restablecido ya el suministro de energía
tras un apagón masivo que afectó a 20 de
los 23 estados de ese país
el gobierno venezolano sostuvo que el
apagón masivo se debía a un ataque en el
sistema eléctrico nacional puntualmente
en la central hidroeléctrica del gurí
que es la principal fuente de energía
eléctrica de ese país suramericano
más temprano conversamos con daniela
zambrano ella es corresponsal de france
24 en la ciudad de caracas la capital
venezolana y nos daba más detalles de
las reiteradas fallas del sistema
eléctrico en ese país escuchemos bueno
naturalmente hay que decir que venezuela
está sumido en fallas con el servicio
eléctrico y una profunda crisis desde el
año 2010 esto no es nuevo para los
venezolanos los nuevos que ha habido una
migración del interior del país a la
capital porque es donde menos hay fallas
y aún así las hay en el servicio
eléctrico por supuesto que esto afecta
en vías de transporte el metro por
ejemplo estuvo cerrado por muchas horas
afecta a los comercios y afecta a la
vida cotidiana pero esto ocurre en el
interior del país casi a diario desde el
2013 todas las estaciones eléctricas
están militarizadas precisamente para
evitar ataques que es la razón que
siempre dice el gobierno cada vez que
hay una falla en el suministro pero
realmente hay una grave crisis eléctrica
desde hace más 10 10 años que no se ha
solventado un estudio realizado por la
universidad de columbia en colaboración
con científicos de la universidad de
hong kong determinaron que la variante
omicron es resistente a las vacunas que
existen actualmente contra el joven y 19
la noticia se presenta cuando el reino
unido- ya registró un récord de
contagios por tercer día consecutivo más
detalles en el siguiente informe
resultados nada alentadores un estudio
elaborado por la universidad de columbia
en colaboración con la universidad de
hong kong determinó que la variante
omicron es resistente a las vacunas
existentes
una característica sorprendente de la
variante omicron es la alarmante
cantidad de cambios en la proteína de
pico del virus que podrían representar
una amenaza para la efectividad de las
vacunas de anticuerpos terapéuticos
actuales omicron fue detectada en
sudáfrica a finales de noviembre y ha
sido declarada como más contagiosa por
la organización mundial de la salud
los autores no descartan nuevas
mutaciones del virus y alertan de que
puede llegar a ser completamente
resistente a los tratamientos actuales y
es que otros estudios sugieren que
omicron también evade los anticuerpos de
personas que superaron la enfermedad
el nuevo estudio sugiere que todas las
terapias actualmente en uso y la mayoría
en desarrollo son mucho menos efectivas
contra omicron si es que funcionan a
pesar de ello los científicos creen que
las vacunas aún brindan una protección
sólida contra enfermedades graves y la
muerte y por ello consideran que una
tercera dosis podría beneficiar con algo
de inmunidad en otros temas la disputa
entre francia y el reino unido- por las
licencias pesqueras está alcanzando ya
otro nivel el gobierno francés anunció
que pedir a la comisión europea llevar a
cabo un proceso jurídico por las
licencias a las que tiene derecho para
que de esta forma el reino unido cumpla
enteramente lo acordado para el break
city
en la disputa de entre francia y reino
unido- por las licencias pesqueras parís
anunció este viernes que reclamará a la
unión europea llevar un proceso
contencioso contra londres el anuncio se
hizo tras la reunión en el elíseo entre
el presidente de manuel macrón y
pescadores franceses y representantes
del gremio el mandatario evocó las
consecuencias del break 7 en reino
unido- específicamente el conflicto que
surgió entre ambas partes relacionado
con las licencias de los pescadores
franceses que trabajan en aguas
británicas
durante 11 meses negociamos de buena fe
con determinación con los británicos y
con los presidentes de las regiones
interesadas ya hemos obtenido el 93 por
ciento de las licencias de pesca
aún quedan algunas decenas de licencias
para obtener son muchos barcos y muchas
familias que debemos defender
absolutamente según lo firmado en el
break city entre el reino unido y la
unión europea los pescadores europeos
pueden seguir trabajando en aguas
británicas a partir de la obtención de
una licencia
creo que el presidente macro mantuvo muy
claro que la lucha sigue y no parará
cuando hayamos obtenido todas las
licencias nos dijo que no quiere dejar y
también propuso que tal vez haya una
negociación que puede ser más local como
por ejemplo con la idea de jersey
francia asegura que aún faltan 73
permisos de pesca para que el conflicto
con reino unido- termine por su parte de
londres asegura que los pescadores que
carecen de la documentación requerida
para obtener la licencia son los que no
han logrado obtener este permiso además
deben demostrar que ya pescaban en sus
aguas el sector pesquero es una
industria relativamente pequeña pero
simbólicamente importante tanto para el
reino unido como para francia
dejamos a europa nos vamos hasta hacia
el jefe de la dinastía gobernante en
corea del norte kim jong-un cumplió 10
años en el poder
ampliamente criticado por occidente por
sus violaciones a los derechos humanos y
sus pruebas armamentísticas se mostró
inicialmente como un reformador debe ser
riguroso y autoritario régimen comunista
que impera en el país asiático sin
embargo la nación continúa cerrada a la
comunidad internacional
se le consideraba menos rígido más
abierto occidente pero al igual que
bashar al assad en síria está claro que
la juventud de una breve estancia en
europa no son suficientes para convertir
a los hijos de los dictadores en grandes
demócratas en corea del norte kim
jong-un que celebra su décimo
aniversario en el poder ha demostrado
ser al menos tan duro como su padre kim
jong-il a quien los ciudadanos han
llegado a rendir un homenaje no siempre
espontáneo en uno de los regímenes más
represivos del mundo y lo que más al
estar aquí en la colina de manzur y ver
la imagen de nuestro gran general kim
jong-il con su sonrisa no puede evitar
que se me salgan las lágrimas
del viejo dicho dice que el tiempo pasa
y todo cambia pero aunque el tiempo pase
seguimos echando de menos a nuestro
general un interés cultural como
invitado al disparar repetidamente
misiles para probar el arsenal de corea
del norte y suponer una amenaza para la
región
el líder autoritario kim jong-un se ha
ganado el apodo de hombre cohete las
esperanzas de cambio ya no convencen a
muchos expertos
cuando se observa la última década con
kim jong-un en el poder para garantizar
su seguridad es muy probable que corea
del norte siga esgrimiento tanto la
zanahoria como el garrote con falsas
conversaciones de paz y con esta
estrategia de brinkmann psíquico juzgar
con profundidad los tres encuentros con
el expresidente estadounidense donald
trump han sido a juicio de observadores
una ilusión y el brote de kobe 19 ha
sido desde entonces una formidable
excusa para que kim jong-un cierra aún
más corea del norte donde amenazan la
hambruna y los controles fronterizos
especialmente estrictos cada vez son
menos los disidentes que logran salir
del país
cambiamos de tema la agencia de noticias
ap que es una de las más prestigiosas
del mundo hizo una selección de las
fotografías del año que reflejan un
resumen de lo sucedido en el mundo a lo
largo de estos 12 meses
américa latina fue protagonista por
múltiples factores como por ejemplo la
pandemia de kobe 19 la migración medio
ambiente las protestas sociales la
violencia y también la desigualdad
[Música]
ah
i
esto en las noticias buenas noches
[Música]